the UN rights employ to Myanmar made her
penultimate visit to Myanmar in January
2017 she's seen here in Rakhine State in
August of that year
Myanmar security forces attack the
mainly Muslim Rohingya minority there
and the Myanmar government has not
allowed young healy to visit since
military commanders said the crackdown
was in response to attacks on security
posts by rahega fighters nearly
three-quarters of a million Rohingya
escaped over the border to Bangladesh
many reported rape torture and abused by
soldiers and Buddhist mobs The Gambia
accused Myanmar of genocide against the
Rohingya and launched a case at the
International Court of Justice last
November Myanmar's leader Aung San su
Chi denied the charges and defended her
country regretfully the Gambia is placed
before the court and incomplete and
misleading factual picture of the
situation in Rakhine State in Nima yet
it is of the utmost importance that the
court assess the situation obtaining on
the ground in recline dispassionately
and accurate for the rahaga
little has changed in Rakhine the still
denied citizenship are unable to move
freely and have little access to health
care and education Myanmar has done
nothing to dismantle the system of
violence and persecution and the regime
to remain in Rakhine live in the same
dire circumstances that they did prior
to the events of August 2017 many have
tried to escape to neighboring countries
risking their lives with people's
smugglers but increasingly no country
wants to let them in the Malaysian Navy
recently prevented a boat carrying
around 200 were hinga refugees from
landing and last week the Bangladeshi
Foreign Minister said two other boats
carrying around 500 people in the Bay of
Bengal wouldn't be accepted either in
the last two years the Rohingya have
also been caught in the fighting between
the Myanmar military and the oricon Army
fighters for the armed group are
Buddhists the UN says fighting has
intensified with near daily reports of
violence
tens of thousands of civilians were kind
and Rohini
have been forced from their homes the
Myanmar government has imposed an
internet blackout in several townships
for months and the government's accused
of arresting journalists and government
critics in her final report to the
United Nations Human Rights Council last
month Lee said the optimism she had when
she started the job six years ago has
been lost and she's watched devastation
and tragedy since Florence lui al
Jazeera Kuala Lumpur